customers develop test and deploy custom
solutions to the cloud you can find me
on Twitter at Jason Taylor Dev or on my
blog jasontaylor.dev
today we're here to look at
authorization with asp.net core basic
approach and a flexible approach
a little bit of background information
before we get started
so authentication is the process of
determining a user's identity whereas
authorization is the process which
establishes which resources a user can
access
authentication is independent of
authorization but it's important to
remember that authorization requires an
authenticated user
so authorization determines access to
resources but what exactly is a resource
well it can be many things inside the
application it could be a page a view or
a capability outside it could be access
to data such as in a database or access
to a file in the file system
authorization also includes defining and
enforcing access control rules as
policies which are then used by the
system to accept or reject Access
Control requests
so in this talk we'll be focused on
authorization
I'll demonstrate how to apply and
enforce access control with basic
authorization capabilities built into
asp.net core
and I'll show you that in some cases
that approach is going to be difficult
to maintain it will take a long time to
develop and it will decrease the overall
maintainability of your system
I'll then demonstrate a flexible
approach to authorization by extending
asp.net course authorization
capabilities and show you how you can
overcome those limitations
now the sample app I'll be using is
built using Blazer webassembly hosted on
asp.net core and at the end of the
presentation I'll share the code and
slides for that application
before we get started we'll have a
little bit of background information on
authorization with asp.net core and then
with blazer webassembly
now asp.net core of course supports
simple authorization capabilities and
that includes allowing an authenticated
user and allowing an anonymous user
it also includes sophisted authorization
capabilities such as role-based
claims-based and policy based so basic
capabilities are very good
it's easy to create custom authorization
policies and what's more it's also easy
to customize the authorization
middleware so you can extend the
built-in authorization capabilities to
suit your needs
at its simplest form authorization
asp.net core requires applying an
authorized attribute to a controller
action or razor page you can see in this
example I've applied the attribute to
the account controller so that means
that any of the actions in this
controller require an authenticated user
and of course that's a problem because
now nobody can log in
so we need to fix that
here I've moved the authorize attribute
down to logout so you only need to be an
authenticated user to log out but anyone
can log in
as another example I've applied the
authorized attribute to the top of the
account controller again and then the
allow Anonymous attribute to the login
asp.net core also supports role-based
authorization in this example we've used
that same authorizer tribute to specify
the role of Administrators to access the
actions within the administrator's
controller so that means an
authenticated user just needs to be in
the administrator's role
next up we specified two roles
administrators and accounts now this
actually means or so you have to be an
authenticated user and you need to be in
either the administrator's role or the
accounts role
in this case I've used the authorizer
tribute two times so first for the
administrator's role second for the
accounts role and this means that an
authenticated user will now need to be a
member of both roles
so you can see that using the authorize
attribute you can combine it in various
ways to set your Access Control policy
it also supports policy-based
authorization again through the
authorized attribute here I've specified
that to access the employees controller
the authenticated user must satisfy the
requirements of the employees only
policy
now it's quite easy to Define policies
you can see here we're doing it when we
add our startup services so add
authorization I'm adding a new policy
called employees only with a single
requirement the requirement is that the
authenticated user must have the
employee number claim the value of that
claim is not important for this policy
next up we'll have a look at
authorization and Blazer webassembly
so it supports the same basic
authorization capabilities because of
course it's an asp.net core technology
also
it includes the same sophisticated
authorization capabilities such as
role-based claims-based and policy-based
view-based resource-based the list goes
on
it also includes helpful authorization
components such as authorized view which
will allow you to selectively display
content on your page and authorize route
view which will be able to restrict
certain routes to certain users
it's important to remember that with
blazer webassembly or really any
front-end web technology that the
authorization is just there to improve
the user experience those checks can
easily be bypassed and so we have to
still enforce authorization on the back
end
so in Blazer we can apply the authorized
attribute to a routable page here I've
restricted access to the home page to
authenticated users
in this case I've opened up the login
page to allow Anonymous in Blazer we can
apply that authorized attribute at a
global level and so here even though all
other Pages might be restricted the
login page remains accessible
with role-based authorization we can use
the authorized attribute and specify the
recommended roles
policy-based authorization again here's
a page we're specifying the employee's
only policy so users requirements of the
employer's only policy
assess this page
so apply the authorized View
display content so the home link
available to authenticated users counter
able to users who are a member of either
the administration the accounts role and
the user's link will only be available
to imp to users who satisfy the
employees only policy
in this case I've specified that the
login nav link is available to users who
are not authenticated
so let's kick off with the first demo
this is a simple one we're going to add
a role to an existing application using
basic authorization capabilities
now I have the sample app this is that
Blazer webassembly I've posted on
asp.net core and it has some
functionality built into it such as
season of users and roles and that sort
of thing so I'm going to start just by
logging in
okay so you can see it's pretty simple
straight out of the box but I've built a
user's page where I'm able to come in
and edit the roles assigned to a user
and I also have a claims page so that we
can view the claims associated with the
user you can see that we're passing the
roles in as a claim so we have access to
that information on Blazer webassembly
what I would like to do is to create a
new auditor role so that I can allow the
auditor user access to certain things
within this application I'd like them to
be able to use the counter
fetch data and view a list of users
so let's see what code changes we'll
need to make to do that
so I have a DB initializer
and in that initializer I've specified
some roles so you can see I have
administrators accounts and operations
I'll duplicate that line
and we'll go ahead and create a Auditors
role
and if I scroll down here we're using
asp.net core identity to create these
roles so I'll duplicate this line too
and we'll create the auditor's role
now that's going to get the role into
the system so I could then assign it to
the auditor but now we need to actually
use that role to secure access
so I'll start with the back end and
securing the controllers
the weather forecast controller is
currently accessible to administrators
and operations so we'll add auditors
I also need to
add access for the user's controller
and the roles controller
now we'll go to the front end and we'll
update the nav menu
let's get rid of that
there we go so you can see here
the counter needs to be updated so this
is the authorized view component we're
specifying the roles for accessing the
counter link
fetch data we'll update that users will
update that that's actually only
accessible to administrators and
administrators sorry claims will update
that to even auditor doesn't really
require that
all right so now that that's done I just
need to restart that application I can
log in as an administrator
and assign that role to the auditor then
we'll log back in as an auditor and see
if we have the correct level of access
okay
here we go
okay so in users we can click edit on
auditor and assign the order to roll hit
in save
then we can log out and hopefully the
auditor will have access to what they
require
logging in
if you're looking for the passwords for
this application of course they're
hard-coded so you can find them in the
DB initializer
I might want to take that out before we
go to production
I'm registering I don't want to do that
and password
one two three exclamation mark
no
there we go
okay
so fingers crossed yes we have access to
the counter page but we don't have
access to it so we have access to the
Canon nav menu That's visible but we
don't access access to the counter page
because I forgot to open that up too so
if we go to the counter page here I have
to update this
you can see it's easy to make mistakes
with this approach
we have to get it right
claims
fetch data
users
so many changes for such a little
requirement
edit
and this is a sample application this is
not an organization a large Enterprise
application
all right let's see if we can get our
reload to do its magic
no
we can that's okay
one last time
it should be okay
here we go
logging in
so we're seeing really an example here
of role-based Access Control
and we're seeing that it's difficult to
maintain and it's time consuming
we tend to make mistakes
and those mistakes are not so easy to
detect
okay counter yes fetch data yes users
we've given them a little bit more
access than what we want we don't really
want Auditors to be able to edit users
but okay we don't really have fine grain
control of these permissions as yet and
we've got claims and we can see that
they're in the Auditors role
so that's it
so in that demonstration in order to add
a single role we had to make code
changes we had to test those changes
when we're ready to go to production of
course we're going to have to push it
through our build and deployment
pipeline the application is going to go
offline just to add a new role and of
course there's probably going to be some
bugs there so we'll have to go back and
fix those we didn't document any of this
so nobody knows who has access to what
it's just in code that shall come to us
as developers and say hey who has access
to what and we'll go we don't know hang
on let me do a full solution code review
and document this for you because the
document is out of date
so that's the basic approach to
authorization with asp.net core using
role-based access control
so what would a flexible approach to
authorization look like
well first and foremost I want it to be
easy to add new roles and to configure
Access Control
I want to be able to also reconfigure
access control for existing roles and I
don't want to have to do a deployment
for that
I want to remove roles without impacting
existing Access Control checks if I want
to remove a role now I have to update a
whole bunch of code to do that
and I want to easily view Access Control
list I don't want the business to come
to me and say who has access to what I
just want that information to be
available to them and automatic not
something that I have to create and
document each time because I'm not very
good at documentation
I wanted to support all of these above
features as standard application
features okay it should be built into
the application
so now let's run this demo again this
time with flexible authorization
capabilities and see how much easier it
is
so this is the same application but
we've extended asp.net causal
authorization capabilities to make it
more flexible
so I'll log in as the admin as before
the admin is the one who's responsible
for managing the roles
now there's a few more pages here you
can see that I have the ability to
manage roles
so I'll go ahead and create a role
I could also
add a sorry I could also update a role
name or delete a role and it will not
impact the code in any way whatsoever
then I have this really nice Access
Control page where on the left hand side
I have defined permissions and across
the top I have the roles and it's easy
for me to assign certain permissions to
certain roles so I'll assign the
auditor's view roles
few users configure access control
that's a bit more access than what I
want them to have but we'll add a new
permission soon
and we'll give them counter and forecast
as well you can see that administrators
automatically get all of the permissions
and actually when I add a new permission
to the system they'll get that too we
don't have to do anything for that
okay those changes have already been
saved it just happens automatically as
we click so I'll log out no I won't log
out I almost forgot I've got to assign
that role to the auditor so we'll jump
over to here
and hit edit
and hit save
there we go
that's like a demo failure averted
so lucky
so now we can sign in as the auditor
localhost
and password
one two three
excellent so we've got counter we've got
fetch data we have users we don't
actually have the ability to edit that's
that's been cleaned up a little bit
we've got our claims we have this
interesting permissions claim one one
seven that number represents the
permissions that the user has we'll
learn more about that later
we've got our roles and we've got our
Access Control they currently got the
ability to change Access Control we
don't want that we'll fix that up with a
new permission
okay
so you've seen the basic approach you've
seen the flexible approach
I think we already know the difference
but let's do a quick comparison with the
basic approach we had to make code
changes there was no way to avoid that
we had to test those changes we did that
manually we have if we deployed to
production we'll have to build and
deploy it the application is going to go
offline we'll probably need to make some
bug fixes along the way for whatever we
missed and we'll need to document those
changes which of course we forgot to do
now with the flexible flexible approach
we weren't really required we just
needed an authorized user or an
administrator to go in and create the
role and to assign the necessary
permissions to that role that just gave
us free time right and that means that
we can focus on building new features or
fixing bugs in some other way delivering
business value rather than looking after
Access Control
so let's have another demo now let's see
how we can use flexible access control
or flexible authorization to add a new
permission to support a new requirement
so we'd like to add a view Access
Control permission so that Auditors have
the ability to view access control and
other users potentially too but not to
configure it not to change Access
Control
we'll stop the application running
so to do this I need to open up the
permissions
file
which I'm currently storing as an
enumeration now depending on how many
permissions you have and the approach
that you would like to take this
enumeration may not work so well with
you but we can discuss other options as
well
so to add the new
Access Control permission I'll just go
view Access Control equal to 128 which
is the next number in the sequence and
we'll talk about how this works and what
flags what the flags attribute means
pretty soon but for now I just want you
to focus on we're adding this new
permission view Access Control
now we need to go to the access control
controller
there might be a better name for that
and here
at the top of the controller we've
specified that for a user to access the
actions within this controller they must
have the configure Access Control
permission so you can see with this
approach it's still nice and declarative
it's a little bit better in fact because
we don't have a magic string we have a
nice strongly typed string to define the
permission
I don't want to apply that permission to
the whole controller any longer
I want to apply view Access Control
let me just copy that
if you access control for get
configuration
and I want to apply
configure access control for update
configuration
okay so the control is done we need to
fix up the nav menu which is on the
front end
so I'll go to the shed components to the
nav menu
and here
scrolling down
where is it there it is so we've got a
flexible authorized view I had to build
a new component to extend the out of the
box authorized view so that I could
Supply permissions
so for this particular one
I want it to allow users to access if
they have
view Access Control
or
configure access control so I'm able to
specify those permissions in fact I can
combine things like the authorize
attribute in different ways to specify
my Access Control policy
so next up I need to open up the page
that's the nav menu so I'll go to admin
Access Control index
and this can be the same
so configure access control or view
Access Control
there we go and that's it for the code
changes now we just need to run the
application
we can log in as administrator assign
the new permission to the Auditors role
and then check it
no we're not finished I forgot one thing
okay so we haven't changed the access
control page to restrict changing
assigning permissions and so to do that
we'll take this little check box
and we'll give it a different state if
the user is authorized to configure
we'll use the flexible authorized view
component
will specify the permissions
and we're going to say if the
permissions dot configure Access Control
if they're authorized
getting a lot of help there but it's not
the greatest help and if they're not
authorized
okay
so if they're authorized we'll leave the
checkbox alone they can go and change
those those permissions if they're not
authorized
we'll just get rid of this change event
and go ahead and set it to disabled that
should do it
okay
so we'll run that and have a look at the
difference that's made
okay I'll log in as an administrator
and we'll go to access control
we see view Access Control we'll assign
that to auditor and we'll revoke
configure Access Control
we can go ahead and log out
and log back in as an auditor
so this code work to do when applying a
new permission
but that's normal we're not we'll
typically do that when we're creating a
new feature or implementing a new Access
Control policy
here we go access control and it's
locked down we can see access control
but we can't change it
all right so I want to give you now an
overview of how this flexible
authorization system works before we
dive into the code and see the actual
engine
we use this system to create the
necessary roles and permissions the
roles are created on the front end using
a component or a page that we've created
and the permissions are created in the
back end and then are available to be
assigned on the front end so we assign
those permissions to roles as required
and this can be done by any authorized
user who has the capability to assign
permissions
we then add those permissions as a claim
to the authenticated user
then we add permissions based Access
Control checks where required we can use
the authorized attribute the
authorized view component and we can use
the asp.net core I authorized service to
enforce those permissions
now the actual engine behind this is ASP
net core policy authorization what we do
is create Dynamic policies to represent
the permissions that have been specified
in Access Control
we also need to manage roles we know
that roles Define a logical grouping of
users that administrators can create the
new roles as required
they can assign permissions to the roles
and we we need to take note that from
this point forward role-based
authorization in our code should be
avoided we're taking those names those
magic strings the roles out of the
application so that our code base is
shielded from those organizational
changes
managing permissions permissions of
course to find granular access to
resources we're much better to describe
exactly what a permission will give a
user than we are if we just assign roles
to various capabilities
developers create permissions as
necessary and permissions are not
assigned directly to a user okay so we
assign permissions to roles and then the
user inherits the permissions of any
roles that they're a member of
the authorization engine as mentioned is
built entirely using policy-based
authorization we saw an example of an
authorization policy it was the
employees only policy which required the
user to have an employee number Claim
well we're building Dynamic policies to
suit the permissions required
so we can use a custom authorized
attribute or other ways to specify
required permissions
and those required permissions are then
translated into a policy name
so we're generating a policy name it's
that policy name that will be used by a
custom policy provider to create the
policy for us
now the policy will be dynamically
created using a custom policy provider
and we're going to see or how all of
that works
so now I'll walk through we'll have a
look at the flexible authorization
engine and how I was able to extend the
capabilities of asp.net core to
implement this and to make our life
easier
okay
we'll start with
permissions.cs we saw that briefly
before
so permissions.cs is an enumeration
it's currently int based and that means
that there's 32 possible permissions
that we can Define for this system if we
change it to long we can have up to 64
possible permissions if we're going to
go over that for a complex application
we'll need to think about a different
strategy for storing our permissions
perhaps we'll put them in the database
and that will change how we add
permissions to the users claims and it
will also change how we produce the
policies to enforce those permissions
but it will be the same engine there
will be some changes required so we're
using flags and that allows us to
combine these permissions in really
interesting ways I created a net
interactive notebook so that we can
explore this together
so permissions in this example are using
the flags enumeration and we have
permissions a through to e now you can
see that those values are in powers of
two we also have some special values
permissions none and permissions all
which is the complement of none
now we can do really interesting things
with these permissions so you can see
here I've defined some user permissions
permissions a
or permission C and if we add the binary
values of these permissions together
which is 1 and 100 we get zero zero one
zero one so these flags represent the
individual permissions of A and C if we
convert that to the integer value or the
decimal value then we get five and
that's the value that was being stored
in the permissions claim and that's how
we know using a single number what
permissions the user has
we also defined required permissions the
same way in this way we've got required
permissions of A or B so if we're
authorizing a user against those
required permissions this user the user
needs to have either permission A or B
in this case the user would be
authorized because they have a
if we add these two permissions together
it's 1 and 10 binary and that converts
to decimal 11 or 3.
so let's have a look at how we can use
this
so first thing I can do is I can just
right line the user permissions to the
console the enumeration and it will give
me the string value so user permissions
a comma C
the required permissions as you remember
will be a comma B
and then I can also output the decimal
value as an in which is 5 and 3.
I can check permissions so we know what
the required and the user permissions
are and they're authorized if they have
that particular permission so either A
or B
here we're using the logical or operator
to add a permission so they have a and C
we're adding B so they now have a b and
c and here we're using the exclusive or
operator to remove that permission so
back to A and C now these operators are
quite nice for adding and removing
permissions but it's not something that
you'll typically do with the flexible
authorization generally speaking the
most that happens is we Loop through the
wall rolls we build up a collection of
permissions for that user and we assign
it to the claim so we're not tending to
operate on permissions in this way but
it's good to know that you can
now here is how we create those Dynamic
policy names that allow us the custom
policy provider to generate a policy for
us we can see the required permissions A
and B we're going to prefix the policy
name with the word permissions and then
we're going to append to that the
decimal value of the permissions
so this particular policy will be called
permissions 3 and based on that asp.net
core will be able to build a new policy
extracting that three and then enforcing
the required permissions and we'll see
how that works
this is the reverse of that code where
we take the policy name permissions uh I
don't know what that one will be a plus
b and c and we take out I think it's
seven and then we take out the
permissions value from the policy name
there we go so we can see from that
value of seven the required permissions
are a b and c and the policy name was
permission seven
oh sorry that was just updating the
required permissions and policy name so
I read that wrong but here's how we can
get the permissions value so we're
taking out the integer value passing it
and then casting it into the permissions
type
so if I run that again permission seven
a b and c
so that's how the permissions CS works
now let's have a look at some other
parts we've got to figure out the best
place to move to next
how about the policy name helper that's
a simple one we can check is it a valid
policy name
we can pass in the policy name and if it
starts with the prefix which is
permissions
uh then we're going to say yes that's
that's a valid policy name we can
generate a policy name given a set of
permissions and that'll be the prefix
and the permissions value
we can get the permissions from a policy
Name by using the prefix length and
grabbing that in value casting it back
to permissions so that's just a nice
little helper function
let's see what else we have
we've got the authorizer tribute custom
claim types are simple the claim name
will be permissions and we've just got a
strongly typed value for that
let's see
that one's just a little helpful one
that I use to get a list of available
permissions where I Loop through the
values of the enumeration and display
the value
so let's get into the important parts
here's the flexible authorization policy
provider
so you can see it's based on the default
authorization policy provider
and there can only be one policy
provider for asp.net core so we base it
on that and we ensure that we retain
calls to the base class to get the
policy
this is where it all happens you can see
in itself building the dynamic policy is
quite simple this is all of it
so first we try to see if the policy has
already been created because this may
not be the first time we've checked
against these permissions
if it has not been created if the policy
comes back as null and it is a valid
policy name it's one of our permissions
policies then we simply extract the
permissions value from it so we have the
value of the enumeration there
then we use the authorization policy
Builder to add a single requirement to
that policy and that requirement is
permission authorization requirement and
we pass in the required permissions we
then build that policy and add it to the
options by policy name and the actual
policy itself
now of course if the policy already
existed we skip all of that and just
return the policy so the policies are
created using a kind of lazy fashion and
if it's already been created once it
will just be returned
we need to look at the permission
authorization requirement now which was
the only requirement of a permissions
policy you can see that it's really just
a container for data it's based on the
eye authorization requirement and it
stores the required permissions
so there's another class that will
actually help us to evaluate that and
it's the policy authorization Handler
there's a little bit of code in here but
in the end it's quite simple first we
find the permissions claim and that
gives us all of the users permissions
then we assess that against the required
permissions and if they're authorized we
simply return context dot succeed with
the requirement and return task dot
completed for anything else we're just
exiting they won't be authorized
let's see what else we have
ah yes sometimes we're writing
procedural code and with asp.net core
when we do that when we want to
authorize procedural code we use the I
authorization service I've extended that
within with a authorized async method
that allows us to pass in permissions
and of course it's then just going to
authorize against a dynamic policy so
all we do is say hey you want to
authorize against permissions then
you'll need this policy which we just
generate the name for on the Fly
yeah
let me see we haven't looked at the
authorizer tribute attribute so the
authorized attribute is based on the
standard out of the box one
all it does is add a new permissions
property which when you set the value
doesn't store the permissions value it
actually just sets the policy name
so you know what we're doing here is
we're saying authorize permissions a
something like that but we could also do
authorize policy equals permissions one
we're just making it easy for the user
to interact with the flexible
authorization system and to specify
their permissions in a very clean and
easy to understand way so we can set the
policy name when we set the permissions
and we can also get the permissions from
that policy name as required
so we've extended asp.net course
authorization but it's still doing all
the work it's just policy-based
authorization under the hood
now there's some other bits and pieces
there
um let me see let me just make sure I
haven't missed anything from this
section
now we looked at that okay how about
inside of authorization on the server
we have the application
user claims principle Factory
and that is the actual class that's
responsible for adding the claim that
contains the user's permissions so you
can see here we get the roles we Loop
through the roles we build up the user
permissions based but the user inherits
all of the role permissions for which
they're a member of and we set the claim
so that's available
there's a little bit of work required on
the front end as well
but the work is there just to take a
take the roles from one format and
convert them into another format
and that just makes it a little bit
easier for us to work with otherwise for
Blazer webassembly raw based
authorization doesn't actually work you
need this little bit of code to get the
roles claim into the right format
oh here's our flexible authorized view
that's the component that we built to
allow us to specify permissions and
therefore selectively show different
components on a page and again it's
driven by policy-based authorization
under the hood
all right I think that's it for the Code
walkthrough does anyone have any
questions on what we've covered so far
yes
[Music]
so so you're saying that for the access
control view where it shows the
permissions you couldn't really show it
to the business because it's not easy to
associate a particular permission with a
page and there's really not that much
information there you could have a
description or something per permission
would be nice and in actual fact I
haven't even put spaces in between the
words so there's definitely some work
that we can do there and one other thing
is to apply some attributes to provide
additional information to each
permission in the flag and of course
that will depend on whether you're using
the enum or whether you decide to take a
different approach for the storage of
your permissions but yeah you can
certainly flesh that out further
cool
all right let's continue slide deck
okay so in summary I've demonstrated
authorization with asp.net core
you saw that with the basic approach to
authorization with asp.net core and
using role-based access control doing
something as simple as adding a new role
took a lot of work we had to write code
we had to build we had to deploy we had
to do bug fixes and we had to document
those changes which we didn't do
and we did fix bugs right I didn't plan
to do that that's just the nature of
that style of authorization It's tricky
to get right
but then we saw the flexible approach to
authorization which was built by
extending asp.net cores authorization
capabilities and we could see then that
adding a new role was trivial
and that adding a new permission took
the expected amount of effort nothing
more than is required
now if your application is simple and it
has a small user base then the flexible
authorization approach is probably
Overkill
if you only have an administrator's role
and a user's role you can definitely get
by with basic approach to authorization
but for most production applications
especially those in large organizations
the flexible approach is essential
it's going to Shield your code base from
organizational changes it'll Shield your
your code base from Department renames
from organizational restructures from
new departments that are forming
it'll only require an administrator or
an authenticated user to maintain those
changes depending on their access level
and that's going to give us free time
time that we can use to fix bugs or
develop to develop new features we'll be
providing greater business value as a
result
thank you for attending my presentation
today thank you for listening and if
you're Keen to learn more you can access
the code and slides on GitHub
so it's on github.com jasontaylordev
forward slash flexible asp.net core Dash
authorization I hope you enjoy the rest
of your conference thank you
[Applause]
thank you
now I've got plenty of time if anyone
has further questions
yes
so different levels of roles yeah so I
guess it depends on how many levels you
need to support for your different
levels of roles to support different
levels of departments one thing that you
can do if it's just two levels then
again it can just be metadata on the
existing roles that can specify kind of
the higher level department but if you
did want to do nested roles and that
needed to be represented in your
application then potentially what you
could do if using asp.net core identity
is to specify a parent role and
basically build up a tree structure and
assign permissions to different levels
of those roles now of course you then
have to decide
are there permissions at different
levels and do I navigate down that
structure assigning those users of the
permissions as I go or will it just be
permissions at the leaf nodes and so
only at the bottom level will the
permissions be assigned so you have to
figure out that for yourself obviously
it'll increase the complexity but in the
end the user just gets that same set of
permissions
any other questions yes
is it so the question is is it possible
to combine this approach with regular
policy-based authorization and yes I
haven't overridden the policy-based
authorization system so you can still
use you can still use policies you can
use roles I wouldn't recommend roles
though you can use resource you can use
view based access control because all I
did was really add permissions based
Access Control
a question
any anyone else
cool let's go get a coffee and enjoy the
rest of the conference thanks everyone
cheers